team white efore oh the typical Sicilian
well let's get some more than
understanding with this I'm saying this
for myself really alop ins variation I
think I could use some more work more
experience in this opening so let's run
with this there's something better than
d4 probably not you do see three so you
follow up with the d4 don't hesitate
there and now I could capture pawn takes
pawn recaptures and then just play a bit
more solidly or I could turn it into an
advanced advanced french where e 5 is
played let's see we're going to see
about that take take night here i'm
going to try that so what we could see
well let's see what black does first
okay now since the pond recaptured it
captures at any moment there could be a
situation where black has an isolated
Queen pond
ok
let's go Knight f3 um
if I capture on c5 I'm going to do it
after this bishop moves for tempo
reasons for time reasons I don't want
that Bishop to go from point A to point
B in one shot so what can I be doing in
the meantime I could pin this night I
don't know how uncomfortable that would
really be can also consider Bishop d3
but I want to be in a position where I
do what where I'm able to recapture on
this square with a piece and if I'm
playing here I'm not able to really do
that I might want to also consider that
the bishop could be quite annoying on
this diagonal so maybe playing to a bit
more solid of a square like e 2 is good
I'm going to do that so it's really
quiet but it's solid I think I could
have also considered b5 and if it gets
kicked around with a 6 I weasel around
in this direction but this pin again
could be quite uncomfortable and I don't
know if I really want to devote some
time to playing h3 just to prevent this
pin and then play my Bishop to d3 a more
aggressive diagonal so more development
again you'll note i'm not taking in this
square until this guy moves or at least
i'm not going to consider it i'm going
to make more i'm going to make other
moves i want to make purposeful moves
like castle like i did like Knight f3
like night g5 maybe even night to d2
Knight d2 is likely going to be a spot
from my night and we will not be having
this exchange so with this structural
change what should happen I think by
force I can get my a brook active so
that's what I'm going to run forward
with right now just try to move my rook
not move not yet at least so this pond
I'm viewing as being overextended
putting pressure on it cannot be
maintained should be five be played I
respond with a four and should a six get
played that's a blunder because this a
pond is really not defending the b5
square because of pin issues because
this rook is unprotected on H on a eight
so there might be aligned b5 a
four-night here let's see about this if
the night plays here i think the move to
go with is night to this square I think
I well I've seen this on the black side
I've seen something similar to this
happening to black in the caro-kann I
think it's quite alright for white here
or after Knight a5 I go with this
particular night to d2 to watch over
both these squares and if you're
wondering maybe why not move this night
to detail it may be because of a
possibility for be four and then
depending on what sort of exchanges
occur then there's a c3 move available
or B takes c3 move available but going
with this King night this night is
around to watch over it so I'm breaking
down the structure let's chop here I
have this open file for my rook or half
open file let's chop again or do I play
night here first I think I just chopped
here again my queen is ready to maybe
come out to this a file you know the
position is opening up also at a moment
where my opponent is two moves away from
castling sometimes just being one move
back from castling could be an issue and
right now there's a couple moves needed
the e-file is completely opened
possibilities for night 83 and well this
is going to turn out to be a serious
problem I'm pretty sure because of pins
checks pressure on the night Bishop may
be coming here so I'm just looking for
the correct sequence of moves and I
think I'll be able to throw black and a
not here this seems very appealing so
I'm going to go with this as a starter
not only for the pin but also at very
that minimum I'm grabbing that c4 upon
there's also a rip check followed by
Bishop 83 rook check or actually let me
do this night here and then rook here is
forced rook to e1 Bishop here I take
seeing it I think I see at night here
rook c8 rook here threatening discover
check Bishop e7 Knight takes Queen takes
Queen takes rook takes rook to a seven
so that there's no rook c7 to defend the
bishop and after night to d5 I think
Bishop 283 ends up winning a piece let's
see if I did that right let's see as far
as I could tell rook here is the only
followed up with this rook move Bishop
e7 needed Knight takes Queen takes Queen
takes rook takes rook takes pawn them on
the bishop twice it's still in a pin not
here to defend the bishop and then one
last attacker Bishop 283 is winning oh I
messed up the move order do you see how
I just um I did that actually this still
might be okay
I meant to do that move first okay so I
I was rehearsing to myself that line
over and over and then what do i do I I
mess it up so I also have checks
available ah you know what this is
better I was thinking after night here I
go here but hang on this is better
change of plans so I did not see that
this variation correctly this is still
winning but it's not best i'm getting
what's better getting a rook or bishop
so this is the better line I don't know
why wasn't well there's a quick mental
note i could be making for myself seeing
that as soon as I'm on this
seventh-ranked the possibilities for
rook to e8 are now available seeing how
the king is not castled the back rank
vulnerable okay
good game let some hit that back button
here flip this screen flip the board and
let's see how things are looking from
your perspective if you really want to
get if you really want to as black to be
assured that it's a more French like
type of position more Frenchy type of
pawn structure you could just take here
and after I recapture then play d5 so
you could maybe turn the well you could
limit my choices by taking here first
and then following up with d5 you give
the game a bit you have an opportunity
to give this game a bit more direction
so now after these this move you're
seeing a way that white is able to take
advantage of this pond being on this
square after b3 there really is not a
way to maintain that pond so that's
that's really the bulk of it at this
point what can you be doing instead of
c4 c4 ms met with b3 and you're not in a
position you have enough development in
to really support it with an eventual b5
type of stuff so what can you be doing
instead how about maybe Bishop here I
take you take and we move forward from
there you're having to work with an
isolated pond but you know you're not
getting killed with your king being
caught in the center that it turned out
that the position was just opening up so
it's an easy easy slip to do I could see
how you would just get caught up in
trying to make it work but just from
this little experience we can know that
it's maybe just turning out to be a case
where the pun is overextended and it's
it's just not the right time to be
running with it so okay that's that's
probably just the main point but
good game to Zuri